"Una de las temperaturas exteriores más
bajas jamás registradas fue de -128° F,
en la Antártica. Una de las temperaturas
exteriores más altas jamás registradas fue de
134° F en el Valle de la Muerte, en California.
¿Cuántos grados de diferencia hay entre la
temperatura exterior más baja registrada y la
más alta?" Así que pensemos un poco en esto. Voy
a dibujar una recta numérica pero, ya que estamos
hablando de temperatura, lo haré de forma vertical
para que parezca un termómetro; y esto de aquí
es 0° F, lo que realmente no tiene importancia,
si fuera Celsius estaríamos hablando del punto
de congelación, pero en Fahrenheit eso ocurre
a los 32°. Esto es 0° F, y marquemos estos dos
puntos: "Una de las temperaturas más bajas jamás
registradas fue de -128° F", así que digamos que
está justo aquí; y "una de las temperaturas más
altas jamás registradas fue de 134°", esto es 134
positivo, aquí están los 134 Fahrenheit. Entonces,
cuando nos preguntan cuántos grados de diferencia
hay entre la más baja y la más alta esencialmente
están diciendo "Bueno ¿cuál es la distancia que
hay entre la más baja y la más alta?, ¿cuál es
esta distancia?" Y hay un par de formas de pensar
en esto, se podría decir "Oye, si comenzara en
la temperatura más baja y quisiera subir hasta la
más alta, ¿cuánto tendría que agregar?" O podrías
decir "Bueno, ¿cuál es la diferencia entre la
más baja y la más alta?" Entonces podrías tomar
el número más grande, 134, y a ésta restarle el
número más pequeño que es 128 negativo. Entonces,
esto esencialmente dice ¿cuál es la diferencia
entre estos dos números? Va a ser positivo
porque restamos el más pequeño del más grande,
esto dará exactamente lo mismo que esto. Ahora,
hay varias formas de pensarlo; una es que sabemos
que restar un número negativo es lo mismo que
sumar el positivo de ese número o sumar el valor
absoluto. Entonces esto será igual a 134 + 128°,
¿y cuál es la intuición detrás de eso?, ¿por
qué pasa esto? Bueno, mira, estamos tratando
de calcular esta distancia, esta distancia es
134 - 128 negativo, y si miras esto verás que
va a ser el valor absoluto de 134, va a ser esta
distancia de aquí que es sólo 134, justo aquí,
más esta distancia de aquí. Ahora bien, ¿cuál es
esta distancia? Bueno, es el valor absoluto de 128
negativo, es simplemente 128, entonces será esta
distancia: 134 + 128, y por eso tenía sentido.
Aquí pensamos en cuál es la diferencia entre un
número mayor y un número menor, pero como es un
número más pequeño y estás restando un negativo,
es lo mismo que sumar un positivo. Espero que
esto le haya dado sentido a esta intuición. Ahora
sí podemos averiguar a qué es igual, y va a ser
igual a -permíteme escribirlo por separado-: 134
+ 128, 4 + 8 es 12, llevamos 1, 1 + 3 + 2 es 6,
1 + 1 es 2, así que nos queda 262. Esto de aquí
es igual a 262. ¿Cuántos grados de diferencia
hay entre la temperatura más baja y la más alta
registrada? Hay 262° Fahrenheit de diferencia.